sind das schauspiel sind im echten leben
polizist weißt du dass es ging um einen
strip poker meine strip-poker wg also um
ganz einmal klatschen aber einfach noch
einmal sonstwas so schwierig sind also
viele klatsche hält was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
wir haben heute ein interview gast und
zwar die nadja ich hoffe dir jetzt auch
gut mir geht es auch gut
ob er sogar das freut mich und er hat
mir auch auf meine interviews
geschrieben was nur gesehen
das habe ich ja auch letztens gemacht
und sie meinte zu mir dass sie mir
fragen beantworten kann zu auf streife
erst haben wir auch ein bisschen über
über frauen redet aber dann das feld
hier leider weg wenn es da draußen
irgend jemanden gibt der über
frauentausch reden möchte super gerne
wir reden allerdings hier heute über auf
streife also kennt wahrscheinlich jeder
von euch dass das format mit den
polizisten wo polizisten irgendwelche
verbrecher jagen oder irgendwelche
komischen geschichten aufdecken ja ist
schon bekannt oder blaulicht report ist
so das ja gut oder auch streich für die
spezialisten
da gibt es ja so viel auf jeden fall hat
sie bei auf streife mitgemacht im
februar gesagt leute und bevor ich die
erste frage stelle erst mal noch eine
frage die wir zum nachhinein aufnehmen
weil ihr euch das wahrscheinlich fragt
oder das wissen wollt worum ging es in
deiner rolle also was muster zu spielen
und was war die handlung von der ganzen
situation vielleicht erklärt das einmal
ganz kurz kannst auch das handy
ich habe ein mädchen gespielt was zu
einer wg gehört hat also es ging um
einen strip poker meine strip-poker wg
also dass ein mädchen sich für die wg
interessiert hat und ich hab ein mädchen
gespielt was bereits da gewohnt hat aber
so tun musste als würde sie sich auch
darauf bewerben und dann haben wir
pokern gespielt und das war dann halt
sonst wird pokern und ja dann ist halt
im endeffekt herausgekommen dass ein
mädchen eingesperrt war und die zwei
jungs aus der serie also in der folge
uns gefilmt hatten und dann ist die eine
mit der leiter hoch geklettert und
wollte das eingesperrte mädchen retten
und ja so ungefähr
und wie lange gegen dann die folge
insgesamt jetzt so 15 minuten oder ok
ich bleibe euch jemand foto 1
und ihr habt mir auf instagram wieder
sehr viele fragen gestellt zu dem thema
und fragen die ich dir jetzt gleich
stellen werde
weil sich sehr viele leute dafür
interessiert haben und schau dir jetzt
mal rein erste frage habe ich allerdings
schon im kopf das ist mal so die
standardfrage um reinzukommen
wie bist du darauf gekommen dass du dir
gedacht dass ich will auf jeden fall bei
auf streife dabei sein
das war sehr spontan also ich bin
morgens aufgewacht und wusste gar nicht
dass da heute zu dem glas hingehe also
ich hab es auf instagram gesehen dass
die einen casting hatten in meiner nähe
das war ein prem okay dann bin ich da
hingegangen und hat mehrere
castingrunden sag mal und dann wurde ich
in die kartei aufgenommen dann lief das
so weiter dann bekam ich immer mehrere
anfragen
[Musik]
und irgendwann kam dann auf streife und
das hat dann also endlich gut gebracht
das war einfach mehr so zufall dass die
ich dafür angefragt habe also ich bekam
auch für klinik am südring oder als hof
gejagt
es war ein zufall weil zeitlich nicht
gepasst hat okay alles klar machen wir
direkt mal oder starten wir direkt mal
weiter durch mit den fragen die so am
häufigsten gestellt hast ja auch gedacht
draußen wo die noch urlaub
draußen sieht man julia an seinem
zigaretten dingen dass quallen und halt
so hat das geht aus als wird da
irgendwas brennen oder so na ja auf
jeden fall machen wir weiter mit der
nächsten frage
dann versuchen sie einmal auf die kamera
zu konzentrieren die polizistin damit
spielen da stellt sich mir auch so die
frage sind sie sind das schauspiel oder
sind sie im echten leben polizist
meister ist ich dachte erst dass
schauspieler werden aber ich habe
nachgefragt und das sind echte
polizisten also diesen sodann
nebenberuflich dafür noch zuständig dass
sie das so als zusatzeinkommen machen
oder oder videos schauen also ich denke
also das sind spezielle polizisten die
damit spielen dass es sind sag ich mal
immer dieselben irgendjemand ich denke
mal die haben sich dazu käme ja
wahrscheinlich gegeben also ihr ja-wort
das ist vielleicht mitspielen und
heiraten wollen und ja wort ja okay okay
weil das das wäre bei mir so also ich
war mir unsicher ob das die polizei
erlaubt weiß dass alles klar interessant
und die fälle die dann da behandelt
werden da habe ich auch gedacht so eine
scheiße kann man sich doch manchmal gar
nicht ausdenken das sind doch
wahrscheinlich alles sachen die irgendwo
schon mal so passiert sind dann so
aufgenommen wurden von der polizei und
das geht dann raus an auf streife die
können wir dann eine sau raus machen
aber du meinst das alles frei erfunden
ich bin mir nicht sicher also ich denke
dass das vielleicht so eine mischung aus
beidem ich denke dass vielleicht ein
teil davon erfunden ist
aber ich denke auch dass vieles davon
wahrscheinlich wirklich passiert ist
okay gut lege die vermutung also ich
hatte halt gedacht ist alles sind alles
fälle die es so schon mal gab so viel
kann man sich ja gar nicht auszudenken
ja eben deswegen ja und manchmal so also
da müssen die die zugibt schreiber schon
irgendwelche drogen genommen haben und
auch sowas zu kommen oder also bei
manchen stories dichter ich habe das
früher mal eine zeitlang sehr gerne
geguckt
genau das läuft ich hab das eine woche
im krankenhaus das kann jeden morgen und
wein und mein zimmer partner
ich hatte so eine op neben mir liegen er
war irgendwie so 275 und er hat das
immer geguckt und ich dachte mir so jo
alles klar
gut kommen wir zur nächsten frage das
ist immer die frage die am häufigsten
gestellt wird wie viel geld hatte
bekommen dass du da mit gefühl das
darfst du zu sagen oder also die von
hilf mir hat 150 euro pro tag bekommen
dass sie damit gespielt hat ich würde
mal sagen das ist wahrscheinlich da ist
die gleiche film bringen es ist ungefähr
ähnlich ok und dachtest du dir okay das
geld dafür oder das dafür dass ich jetzt
im fernsehen bin und alles eher zu wenig
oder weiß nicht dass wir so naja oder
muss auch nicht darauf an worden doch
ich antworte darauf also ich habe mir
vorgestellt dass es vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr wäre aber ich habs jetzt
nicht wegen dem geld gemacht er um
einfach mal die erfahrung zu sammeln
daher war es dann halt auch nicht
spielen aber könne ja alles klar also
150 euro für wie lange dritter wie lange
habt ihr gedreht
zehn minuten und auch direkt im ersten
anlauf ja ja das längste war eigentlich
das warten also
man ist halt zu der produktion hin
gefahren das ist ja anhört so mehr
ländliche ja was ist schön da stand auch
schon hier in köln sagt man so hört
wohnen die ganzen bauern aber ich komme
vom land naja also man ist da
hingefahren dann hat man erstmal was
unterschrieben und seine daten abgegeben
sag ich mal
dann hat man sich mit den anderen
getroffen die mit gespielt haben dann
haben jetzt alle so ein bisschen kennen
gelernt dann gab es ein bisschen buffet
also das war halt in den sehr langen
wartezeit mit buffet sogar brötchen und
so ein bisschen schokolade haus war
schon schön aber das hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht dass es da sogar catering gibt
und die haben die das muss man ja auch
sagen auch komplett anreise und hotel
bezahlt vier-sterne-hotel ja erst recht
wenn man keine großen ansprüche hat dann
wahrscheinlich schon für einen also
sagen kleines hotels ein kleines zimmer
und grenzt aber reicht ja ja das war nur
so weil das war beim letzten mal auch so
der ist das hat glaube ich auch
übernachtung bezahlt und irgendeinem
ranzigen hostel oder so ja gut aber das
heißt du hast dann insgesamt zehn
minuten gedreht und was durch ja also
ich war da bestimmt fünf stunden also
ich hab wirklich erst an sich sollte um
12.30 da sein und dann dachte ich okay
dann geht das um 13 uhr los das ging
dann so um 15 uhr los dass wir dann an
den drehort gefahren sind es ist das
sind ja mal wohnungen die freigestellt
werden für sowas und als wir dann da
waren hat das zehn minuten gedauert und
dann liegen dass haltlos und der
trägerin also
haben nicht eine pause gemacht wir haben
durchgedreht das hat echt 19 minuten
gedauert klar also 150 euro für zehn
minuten ist an sich aber trotzdem auf
eine lange anreise und so gehen wir mal
über zunächst frage das habe ich mich
also ich habe die ganze zeit in einem
haus gedreht und nicht draußen pasta
mitbekommen wie so weil das war die
frage wie die passanten die dann an
sowas vorbeilaufen reagieren oder weil
eben ich finde es aber krass wenn man
sowas schaut da läuft ja nie einer
hinten ins bild und bringt so dumm und
14 total lustig weiß gibt es leute die
räder an den bürgersteigen stehen und
sagen da wird gedreht bitte einfach
vorbeigehen tja da gibt es leute die
stehen da das ist doch abgesperrter
stehen auch ein paar autos vor
also ja ok ach so ja gut weil da habe
ich mich immer gewundert
ob halt wirklich so dann so low budget
produktion den aufwand betreiben das
abzusperren und auch leute da
hinzustellen die sagen wenn du hier lang
gehst oder noten oder da halt wirklich
nur leute langen die auch bezahlt werden
lang zu gehen
ja krass ok interessant eine frage die
ich so 2 mal gelesen habt und zwar unter
leute gefragt ist das deiner meinung
nach schlecht gespielt oder schlecht
gefaked oder dachtest du so ok
eigentlich kam ich schau spielerisch gut
davon also die polizisten haben das ja
das stimmt das finde ich auch rollen wie
heißt dieser eine noch mal das ist so
ein älterer den finde ich total witzig
also der steht ja immer und dramatisiert
dann so richtig die situation also ja
ich würde sagen so ein mittelding ich
würde mal sagen jeder ist
unterschiedlich gut gibt vielleicht
welche diese ein bisschen besser ein
bisschen schlechter aber so würde ich
sagen okay ein bisschen schulen weil das
ist ja so das ding was dann viele immer
dann kritisieren so war super
schauspielerische leistung aber es kann
ja auch nicht perfekt sein und die
pistolen von den polizisten
dabei haben sind die echt oder ist das
die rechte dienstkleidung oder weißt du
das nicht das weiß ich nicht aber ich
kann mir vorstellen das ist echt ist
bietet sich ja dann auch andere weil man
muss ja auch sagen die haben ja schon
manchmal die haben ja schon manchmal
fachwissen raus deswegen
hättest mich gewundert wenn das immer so
nach drehbuch wenn ihr das
auswendiglernen genau das dann so
wiedergeben können und vor allem
authentisch also das bestätigt dieses
dass es echte polizisten sind und das
ganze läuft aber nach dem drehbuch ab
also muss das text auswendig lernt ja so
wir haben ein drehbuch bekommen das
hatte so ungefähr zehn seiten und da
stand halt die situation und da stand
auch die rolle
wir haben aber das meiste war
improvisation also am ende komplett
anders gespielt eigentlich es war aber
trotzdem gut ja aber ich habe ja letztes
hierbei können so kraft klassenfahrt ja
ja ja da haben wir das auch alles mit
improvisation gelöst war aber hat
richtig spaß gemacht so was macht ein
spaß eigentlich nur gut zwei fragen habe
ich noch ich muss sagen ich persönlich
finde jetzt nicht so interessant aber
dass stellen viele wurdest du deswegen
schon mal dann auf der straße
angesprochen weil du damit gemacht hast
ja ein paar mal also dreimal ungefähr so
cool war das waren eher bekannte leute
die ich auch ja ja ja jetzt keine
weltfremden 100 ok und so das ganze
vielleicht ein bisschen abzuschließen
würdest du sagen ich hab doch noch mal
mitzumachen oder war das eine einmalige
sache und du denkst du jetzt so schön
mal mitgemacht zu haben aber muss auch
nicht noch mal sein
es kommt darauf an also ich denke wenn
jetzt vielleicht irgendwann mal die
passender zeitpunkt ist und die haben
eine interessante wahl über dieses spiel
machen das waren schon alle fragen also
wir sind endlich durch ja welche ich
habe jetzt glaube ich zwölf fragen
gestellt oder so mehr habe ich auch
nicht weil das sind alles fragen die
sich einfach nur wiederholt haben
deswegen hier hast du jetzt kommt sogar
dann das auf streife set das in kürze
als mainz das geht jetzt hier gerade
weil wir 17 minuten 5 ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen
danke dass du dir die zeit genommen hast
und dabei war es wie gesagt an euch
falls ihr mal irgendwo mitgespielt habe
und bock habt darüber zu reden schreibt
man bei instagram da ist ja alex wie der
dienst schreibe ich auch sehr gerne in
die kommentare weil da fragen wir viele
nach so weil
vor allem sodann 14 jähriger junge ist
[Gelächter]
das war's ich bin schön tag morgen um 19
uhr gibt es neues video haut rein